and in part two of our job search series
are you a stay-at-home mom or dad who
wants to return to the workforce well
perhaps you
maybe have been caring for an elderly
parent kirsten joyce has you covered
with great advice from our career
counseling expert kirsten
denise there are so many valuable
stay-at-home mom dad transferable skills
that you've gained from being a parent
or a caregiver
that you can leverage in your career i
work with a lot of
stay-at-home moms and dads who um
you know have been out of the workforce
for a while and i say
you know you have a lot of a very
important skills that you've developed
in that time
even think about all the arguments that
you
you put out the mediation the conflict
resolution
skills that you develop the scheduling
the logistics the transportation um
the the fiduciary and billing
alice rush says give yourself credit for
those very real transferable skills as
work experience
and document that on your resume with
child care or elder care
you can use these skills to compensate
for the employment gap in your resume
add planning
communication skills crisis management
financial management abilities to that
resume as well
she shares the following example of one
prior stay-at-home mom's
new career i said how did you get into
getting this job and manufacturing and
you were a stay-at-home mom
and she said i told the hiring manager
all the things that i did
during the day of managing all the
schedules for the
six kids and providing transportation
and getting them to and from
places and he was so impressed with my
organizational abilities and attention
to detail
that he hired me don't forget time
management
creative skills and mentoring skills as
you think about all those innovative
games you had to come up with during the
afternoons
and of course the ultimate mom dad skill
negotiation
plus you can add event planner on it as
well if you've organized socials and
parties play dates birthday events
you get the idea